hello guys i'm ryan right nice telugu
stella chu is she's uh what is the
proper way but it is a cosplay player
cause book please well i'm just a
cosplayer cosplayer okay so that's the
way to put it she has a youtube channel
her facebook is [ __ ] blown up with
followers people and here's some photos
to see why she's blown up with followers
let the photos in dead space dead space
now you guys are happy anyway today
we're gonna do an unboxing video
Stella's give you my co-host who's gonna
present each item to me one at a time do
not let me see what's in the item ok
what's embarrass next I forgot what the
theme is in there is a pamphlet that
will tell you what the theme is uh huh
you must find that pamphlet cuz I never
remember what the theme yeah here's your
knife to open the box oh god what could
go wrong what could go wrong ok so the
theme is chaos chaos October 2015 chaos
all right let's go one item at a time
Stella ok I'm handing you the item yeah
you'll probably know what it is better
than I will ok alright cool wow oh wow
oh wow I'm getting an evil dead vibe me
too I'm totally getting Evil Dead vibe
yeah it's definitely inspired by evil
dead no [ __ ] way I love evil dead i
recently did a sketch that was really
inspired by evil dead certain moments
and i [ __ ] love evil dead oh my god
does it been I know it's like the
coolest [ __ ] ever I stopped to watch the
show have okay there's a show now yeah
people dead show ash vs. Evil Dead yeah
stars Bruce camp ok oh this oh you can't
put it on though away you can't put it
on mmm-hmm I just slips in old fist four
fingers up all all five fingers you
should watch sellers for less video
she's fingering doughnuts
look at that oh it's like a baseball
like you got it whoo yuval dad evil damn
this this chopping it up okay governor I
have this myth you only have one hand
one year one that cuts things up you're
really long nails oh thank you I mean
it's a compliment to low angle okay all
right so this is it's a bandana of venom
is really cool that is really cool let's
go start right you look really
intimidating with that oh yeah look
really in German today without it but
this is this adds to my intimidation
point Oh totally there you go Brad oh my
god and what well if you had a tone
debit okay nope I made a promise I would
not make jokes like that all right here
is this guy it is good oh yeah as it
goes from Mario right yep it's oh it's a
air freshener oh let's see what it
smells like okay let's use the air
freshener now ah smells decent yeah
super geek box I know I'm unboxing your
box right now but are they I can't tell
if it's the same smell on each side or
not was it smell like soap Oh smells
like soap I was hoping you were gonna
say like happiness no well like Mushroom
Kingdom mm-hmm no starts with the P
Pokemon know it's odd there's an S in
between two S's [ __ ] hahahaha q Thank
You we finally got to better appreciate
good I think about ah we have these pop
rocks yes yeah let's do that pop rocks
here's how your husband and you make out
take a couple of pop rock shouldnt
mm-hmm all right next one yes baby come
out here look what I got you're gonna
love this it's for you I'm gonna give
this to you I finally got a present I
could give to you she just covered a
song from Nightmare Before Christmas
that's rad here you go baby take it chew
it think of me be in the bedroom alone
with it you know what to do all right
and then there's also a little in a
little pin yeah to go good I Nightmare
Before Christmas pin can you guys see
that I'm not gonna focus it for you
sorry this is the coolest one so far
honestly that's like the coolest one
yeah hanging up on your wall I will it's
too bad you got it like right after
Halloween could have had it on Holly I
was supposed to unbox this before
Halloween ah but not on top of schedule
a little lazy all right shirt here's
t-shirt what is it I don't think I can't
see it that is the coolest [ __ ]
little bits of bad is that is so cool
it's funny bone what's not funny all
right not funny Stella I want you to
know that I've seen your cosplay photos
but I'm in much better shape than you
okay so prepare to be intimidated by the
sex like my girlfriend's the other room
so don't and you're gonna become like
incredibly attracted to me because
finally just look that good but I'm
gonna rock this shirt right now yes dude
yeah and I'm sitting I'll try and hold
myself back just beware that's people
texting you'd be like make sure Stella
keeps back right now oh yeah see I can
do burlesque too yeah there you go there
you go mm-hmm mmhmm yeah it's a classic
move yeah oh damn I'm a burlesque dancer
now I'm gonna totally wear this
and it feels really comfortable too
super soft you could totally see my
nipples do tonight there's a trick
actually you put your hand and
somebody's right here grab nipple I just
showed you trick on how to find a guy's
nipple really yep Center oh and you just
reach done is it worked for girls nope
how unfortunate leche how unfortunate
well guys that's the super geek box
unboxing video today oh and I already
broke some of the myth that's great I
need a new one super geek box so what
you guys can do is you can get a super
geek box in there's a in the description
link there's a referral link to get one
right there and no I don't earn any
money if you guys buy one I do in fact
he does yeah this is her a product
placement goes to me all twenty dollars
a weird it's enough forever for like a
good nice lunch like to chipotle burrito
yeah oh yes chipotle we're looking for
sponsorship anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe today and become
a reject Cox it's the new one for today
you want for today still a cheer you can
follow her on her facebook but she has a
youtube channel up where you can see
videos of her vlogging and somewhere for
cosplay videos so you could see those
pictures in motion picture yeah there
you go guys so and she's got a wonderful
personality too yeah see she's more than
just look she's she's got some things
happening she's got a brain may be
sparking am you want women to believe
they have a brain human right way to
play along way to play along good back
and forth you guys yeah